oh that's Bourbon Street live right now
Fat Tuesday Lent begins in about an hour
and ten minutes what are you giving up
our own Raymond Arroyo and New Orleans
native insisted twisted my arm that I go
down to the Big Easy ride and my first
Mardi Gras parade who could pass that up
it was an adventure and we wanted to
bring you all along on this Mardi Gras
day so check it out
[Applause]
silora Mardi Gras began in 1699 here
when Jean Baptiste Bienville landed
about 60 miles south of New Orleans and
they celebrated the first Mardi Gras
here now it was actually it gained steam
in Mobile Alabama but then very quickly
once New Orleans was founded in 1718
this became the epicenter of Mardi Gras
[Music]
as time went on these mardi gras crews
got bigger and bigger and remember this
is not just any festival this is our
pre-lenten preparation because remember
in the old Catholic rites
you couldn't have beat you couldn't
drink during the 40 days of Lent so you
had a blowout from the Epiphany on
January 6th till Ash Wednesday that's
what this is Mardi Gras
[Music]
we have to wear costumes and a saying
I'm from Connecticut like we will we
have like a Memorial Day parade or like
this Girl Scouts marswell
veterans on New Orleans things are a
little different you have everybody who
parades in a crew has to wear a costume
and you must wear a mask it is actually
against the law to not mask anything on
you Laura and for the Mon here we go all
right we're rolling let's do it part of
every food when you come in before you
load on the floats you have to make sure
that all of your throws are written
[Music]
it's the float we're riding it is the
largest float of Mardi Gras six separate
cars this is not as easy as it looks
Ingram all right Laura your first Mardi
Gras ride which is like it's called all
right you came to town that's why it's
so it's incredible it great we've
already met great friends we have a lot
of new friends on the float everybody's
drinking just water
that's a holy water only water
[Music]
having article is just unbelievable
we made it in one piece I have to tell
you it's a long day it's a long day but
the base is the smiles of the people on
the street
[Music]
okay well Raymond said we shouldn't
throw all the good beads early because
would run out we get to the convention
center where all the people are we had
four bags of beads left over and we said
to leave them behind it was redeemed
there was so much fun my favorites
throwing the footballs I've got to say
there's more where that came from when
we give them back with the last fight
and I brought back some of the beads